hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about a way of classifying antibiotics
this is broad-spectrum versus
narrow-spectrum antibiotics so first
we'll talk about the broad-spectrum
grouping and the antibiotics are
classified as a broad-spectrum
antibiotic if they are generally
effective against a really wide range of
bacteria particularly gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria sometimes this
term broad-spectrum antibiotics is used
more subjectively meaning to refer to an
antibiotic that is broadly applicable
against a wide variety of pathogens that
cause disease but that's a fairly
subjective sort of characterization and
so more often we see gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria it has to be
effective against members of both of
these classifications in order to be
considered broad-spectrum now
gram-positive and gram-negative we're
not going to go into really what that
means although I do have another video
on that topic if you're interested but
that's different ways of characterizing
bacteria based on the type of cell wall
that they have now winter broad-spectrum
antibiotics used well they're used when
it's been determined that a patient has
a bacterial infection but the causative
agent has not been specifically
identified this is what we call empiric
therapy
so a doctor has said hey this person has
has a bacterial infection and don't
quite know what kind of bacteria is
causing it and their symptoms are severe
enough that we need to be treating them
immediately we don't have time to figure
out exactly what the infection is being
caused by we've got to treat it now so
I'm gonna use a broad-spectrum
antibiotic for this
some examples include ampicillin
tetracycline somewhat ciprofloxacin
sometimes it's just called cipro these
are ones that you might have heard of
elsewhere but broad-spectrum antibiotics
are not without risks the two main risks
we'll talk about them the first one is
the development of antibiotic resistance
this is something that you may have seen
on the news it's a growing problem in
our healthcare system and this is when
bacteria are developing resistance to
our antibiotics and so our antibiotics
no longer work to fight infections
caused by those specific strains or
species that are resistant to that
antibiotic and it's definitely a growing
problem we have bacteria that are
becoming more and more resistant even
examples of PAM resistant bacteria
this bacteria that are resistant to all
known antibiotics and we as a community
really need to get some new antibiotics
developed if we want to be able to
continue fighting these infections
another big risk to the use of these
broad-spectrum antibiotics is that they
may disrupt the microbiome
remember that we as individuals have
lots and lots of good beneficial
symbiotic bacteria living within us
whether it is on our skin and our gut in
our reproductive tracts we have lots and
lots of bacteria this is called our
microbiome they do many things for us
they helped our immune system Prime
there's bacteria in our gut that make
vitamin K for us bacteria in our gut
that help us to break down our food so
that we can get nutrients from our food
more effectively they do lots and lots
of good things for us unfortunately if
you take a broad-spectrum antibiotic its
effective against a wide range of
bacteria it can kill off your good
symbiotic bacteria at the same time that
it's killing off the pathogen and so
that's a big issue with broad-spectrum
antibiotics and the reason that you
don't want to use them if you can use a
narrow spectrum antibiotic instead and
I'll switch our focus to talking about
the narrow spectrum antibiotics these
are ones that are effective against only
a specific group of bacteria so this is
when a doctor is able to say hey you
have a bacterial infection based on your
symptoms or lab tests we can be certain
that it is caused by this particular
kind of bacterium and so narrow spectrum
antibiotics can be prescribed when the
causative agent when the bacterium the
type of bacterium that is causing the
disease has actually been identified
so perhaps a sample taken by the doctor
has shown that it is definitely some
kind of grand positive bacterium or
based on symptoms and tests and in a
hospital the doctor knows that you're
infected with some kind of micro
bacterium for example maybe you might go
bacterium tuberculosis or something like
that and so it's been identified and the
doctor can prescribe a narrow spectrum
antibiotic one that is specifically
effective against just that group of
bacteria that a person is infected with
some examples of this include penicillin
basic trace in polymyxin antibiotics and
in general this narrow spectrum
antibiotics because the causative agent
has been identified instead of being
called an empiric therapy this is
referred to as a definitive therapy
and importantly it has fewer risks
compared to using these broad-spectrum
antibiotics it's not going to disrupt
the microbiome at least not nearly as
severely an antibiotic resistance is
only going to be a concern within this
specific range of bacteria rather than a
very broad range of bacteria so fewer
risks and so this is the preferred type
of therapy to prescribe a narrow
spectrum antibiotic rather than a broad
spectrum and so about antibiotic and
that's just whenever it's possible there
are times when a doctor is going to be
forced to prescribe a broad-spectrum
antibiotic generally because they don't
know exactly what's causing the disease
but the patient's symptoms are severe
not that something has to be done
immediately if you are interested in
learning more about grande positive and
gram-negative bacteria check out my
video on that topic if you're interested
in another way to classify bacteria
that's bass or excuse me um to classify
antibiotics that's based on their
mechanism of action against bacteria you
can check out my video on bacteriostatic
versus bactericidal drugs a bit for
today thanks for watching biology
professor